oder man muss ihm auch klar waren das
ist ein abenteuer wäre aber erwägt das
sehr ernsthaft praktisch die hälfte der
russischen armee ist aufgeboten von ihm
an der grenze der ukraine und das muss
man ernst nehmen das ist die ernsthafte
gefahr dass russland krieg führen will
und wenn man jetzt in der
entscheidungsphase einfluss nehmen will
dann muss man sagen das wäre teuer das
würde in der kalkulation für russland
nicht aufgehen und deswegen muss man
alles auf den tisch legen die frage an
die nato-strategie stefanie barz der die
usa haben jetzt 8500 soldatinnen und
soldaten in alarmbereitschaft gesetzt
mehrere nato-staaten dänemark
niederlande spanien sind es bieten
schiffe und flugzeuge für einen einsatz
in osteuropa an ist dieses zu erhalten
diese entscheidungen der nato die jetzt
getroffen worden sind nicht gerade
zitiert haben genau die richtige
reaktion auf ein aggressives gebannt an
der ukrainisch-russischen grenze
also die nato hat ja eine
doppelstrategie gegenüber russland schon
immer gefahren und das tut es jetzt auch
noch eine abschreckung
verteidigungsbereitschaft zu zeigen und
gleichsam auch den dialog anzubieten
das erste ist bereits passiert wir haben
in der vergangenen woche ja den erst
nach russland gehabt und ich persönlich
hoffe dass es noch weitere gespräche
geben wird aber die verstärkung der
militärischen abschreckung und
verteidigungsfähigkeit ist eine relativ
logische konsequenz und ein handeln das
zu erreichen das heißt das ist zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt auch schon notwendig
also es gibt ja nicht gerade geringe
ängste und befürchtungen in unseren
mitgliedstaaten insbesondere in polen in
den baltischen republiken aber auch in
anderen mitgliedstaaten das sagen was
eine mögliche
militärische intervention in ihrer
unmittelbaren nähe bedeuten würde und
dementsprechend hand die nato staaten
zusammen darauf reagiert und beschlossen
die verteidigungsbereitschaft
noch einmal zu erhöhen um unter beweis
zu stellen dass das bündnis in der tat
seinen mitteln der bereit ist so
verteidigen
das thema der sendung ist ja ob es
sinnvoll ist die ukraine auch mit waffen
zu beliefern
da gibt es eine klare haltung der ampel
koalition ist ein no-go keine
waffenlieferung schon gleich gar nicht
in spannungsgebiete was es ja jetzt auch
wer ob das ein ganz normales
spannungsgebiet ist werden wir im laufe
der sendung ja noch besprechen jetzt
gibt es aber bereits waffenlieferungen
dazu mindestens ankündigung der usa
großbritannien tschechien litauen das
hatte ich bereits begonnen heißt das
dass das sind ja alles nato partner von
uns dass wir da schon wieder eine
unterschiedliche geschwindigkeit in der
reaktion auf die situation in und an der
ukraine haben ich halte von der
militarisierung der dinge nichts wir
haben
sechs jahrzehnte frieden in europa wir
reden nicht über stadt land fluss
sondern wir reden über wirklich
dramatische verhältnisse in den krieg
mitten in europa hätten zwei flugstunden
von berlin entfernt und deswegen ist die
stunde der diplomatie gekommen die aber
weitem nicht ausgeschöpft ist und gerade
deutschland deutschland hat mehr als
jedes andere land die verpflichtung sich
um diplomatie zu bemühen dass man die
format soll wiederbelebt werden die
minsker vereinbarung werden von beiden
seiten nicht eingehalten wir wissen dass
es keineswegs veraltet dass es nur
gemeinsame sicherheit in europa gibt
oder gar keine das ist eben erkenntnis
die wir auch haben und natürlich muss
klar gemacht werden dass wir die
territoriale integrität nicht verletzen
dürfen aber das macht man eben hinter
verschlossenen türen in diplomatischen
froh darüber dass die jetzt auch
hergestellt werden die gespräche zu
glauben wir schaffen das jetzt mit
wechselseitiger hochrüstung und wir
machen da mal ein paar november da und
da und dann findet das statt das ist
nicht richtig werden übrigens bei den
helsinki vereinbarungen haben auch die
russen unterschrieben dass man sich
nicht nur ein völkerrecht hält sondern
dass wir militärische einsätze nur zur
verteidigung des eigenen bündnisses
unternehmen die frage sondern daran hält
im moment das ist die hoffnung die man
haben muss ich weiß nicht wo das enden
das ist wahr aber das ist die hoffnung
dass das so ist und man fragt sich oder
nutzen liegen sollten das ist
innenpolitische motive geben kann sich
nach außen so zu gebärden das kennen wir
nicht nur von russland das haben wir
auch im eigenen bündnis schon erlebt in
den letzten amerikanischen präsidenten
denke an seinem vorletzten aber dass man
am ende ernsthaft erwägt
einzumarschieren das kann man nicht
hoffen und die diplomatie wird tätig
befindet gutes der bundeskanzlerin
französische präsident heute
zusammengekommen sind und darüber
sprechen aber ich würde nicht so
leichtfertig über damals
truppenbewegungen dort waffen hinbringen
die holler deutschland muss eine andere
sein wir müssen alles dafür tun dass
diplomatie vorn gemacht die
diplomatischen aktivitäten sind nicht
ausgeschöpft sagt ralf stegner da können
sie sich angesprochen fühlen denn sie
sind ja schon ein befürworter von
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine zur
verteidigung zur möglichen
verteidigungen dieser situation naja
natürlich sind die diplomatischen
möglichkeiten nicht ausgeschöpftes geht
weiter aber zu recht darauf hingewiesen
dass endlich wieder der nato russland
rat tagt funktioniert das geht
hoffentlich weiter es finden mehrere
gespräche auf verschiedenen ebenen statt
zwischen den usa und russland direkt auf
die europäische union wird engen
einbezogen aber wir sind doch jetzt in
einer entscheidungssituation in der
kollege stegner sagt militarisierung
dann muss man doch klar sagen hier hat
ein land ein player militarisiert und
das ist russland und dem muss man jetzt
etwas entgegensetzen und natürlich muss
man immer ein diplomatisches angebot
machen aber man muss am ende zur
verteidigung der ukraine auch klar sagen
da wird man auch militärische mittel
benötigen und die frage ist schlägt man
das von vorne von vornherein aus der
hand von letzten mal die ukraine an der
stelle auch im stich das ist ja nicht
irgendein landes ist ein
parlamentarisches demokratisches land in
europa dem russland wir alle
souveränität und auch unverletzlichkeit
der grenzen zugesichert haben und an
dieser stelle muss darf man aus meiner
sicht nicht tatenlos sein wer da nichts
tut kann sich genauso schuldig machen
wie jemand der etwas tut und keiner von
uns ja irgendetwas offensives sondern
nur massnahmen zur verteidigung und an
der stelle muss ich sagen von vornherein
zu sagen wir schlagen auch nato-partnern
alle möglichkeiten aus der hand der
ukraine auch zu helfen auch mit
defensiven waffen halte ich nicht für
richtig und nicht für verantwortbar pro
lampe wenn ein land noch nicht genannt
das auch waffenlieferant sein möchte
estland die wollen nämlich
panzerhaubitzen an die ukraine liefern
jetzt gibt es ein problem diese
panzerhaubitzen sind alter bestand der
nationalen volksarmee sind sowjetischer
bauart sind von deutschland irgendwann
mal nach estland geliefert worden das
ist ja unproblematisch das ist ein
nato-partner
jetzt stellt sich deutschland da
möglicherweise quer ist das die richtige
haltung deutschlands dar so einzugreifen
dass er möglicherweise was manche
kritiker glauben ein falsches signal an
putin sendet
also die waffenlieferungen durch
deutschland werden ja sehr streng
kontrolliert und keine waffen in
krisengebiete das ist ein grundsatz der
außenpolitik deutschlands ist auch
völlig richtig und hier in diesem fall
geht es eben um schwerer artillerie
deswegen hat die bundesregierung
offenbar hier bedenken zu sagen das sind
reine defensivwaffen die sie nach meinem
verständnis auch gar nicht sinn sondern
es sind waffen schwere waffen die man
dort liefern würde in die ukraine von
island aus die tatsächlich auch zum
angriff genutzt werden also deswegen ist
diese frage wichtig aber sie ist ja auch
nur ein teil thema des großen themas wie
soll man die ukraine am besten
unterstützen gut wenn sie wenn wir kurz
bei der waffenlieferung noch bleiben ist
denn die ukraine genauso ein
spannungsgebiet wenn man jetzt sagt im
koalitionsvertrag steht wörtlich eben
drin keine waffen in krisengebiete in
spannungsgebiete liefern ist es aber das
spannungsgebiet gleich spannungsgebiet
oder macht es einen unterschied ob wir
von mali von wenn von afghanistan reden
oder eben von der ukraine an land mit
dem wir auch freundschaftlich verbunden
sind
ja also zunächst mal es gibt ausnahmen
zu diesem grundsatz das war zb der fall
dass wir
raketenabwehrsysteme an die verschwörer
in nord irak geliefert haben damit die
per schmerker den die terror miliz die
es bekämpfen können da hat man waffen in
ein krisengebiet geschickt das ist aber
die große ausnahme und die ukraine hat
einen internen konflikt das darf man ja
nicht übersehen im südosten der ukraine
ist eine separatistische bewegung
unterwegs der krieg dauert jetzt acht
jahre also es handelt sich tatsächlich
auch um eine interne schweren
bewaffneten konflikt das ist das eine
und das andere
also wir müssen auch bedenken die
ukraine ist nicht nato-mitglied also das
scheint in der diskussion immer so ein
bisschen zu verschwimmen dass wir uns
genauso gegenüber der ukraine verhalten
müssten wie wir uns zum beispiel
gegenüber polen oder lettland die in der
nato sind verhalten müssen im
verteidigungsfall die ukraine ist eben
nicht ein bündnispartner und ist nicht
in der nato
papst wenn man das jetzt hört ist das
hat die ukraine soll sie das pech nicht
in der nato zu sein deswegen kriegen sie
auch keine waffen denn dieser konflikt
denen frau lemke da angesprochen hat er
ist ja auch von außen aufgezwungen
worden muss man da so formal korrekt
oder klar ablehnend vorgehen zu sagen
also da können wir auf keinen fall
waffen hin liefern
aus meiner sicht gibt es da dass er
dinge vielleicht
rückseitigen sollte zunächst einmal noch
mal zur grundsatzfrage waffenlieferungen
mir scheint es so zu sein dass es
eigentlich zwei hauptargumente geht die
immer ins feld geführt werden wenn es um
mögliche waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine geht zum einen sollen sie
ausdruck politische solidarität mit kies
seien so meinen die einen die anderen
argumentieren die waffenlieferung
könnten letztendlich quasi die kosten
also die militärischen kosten oder das
kalkül für russland erhöhen beide
argumente scheinen mir nicht wirklich
stimmig zu sein denn letztendlich ja was
auch immer an wachen geliefert wird wird
zumindest gegenwärtig nicht den
qualitativen nachteil der militärischen
nachteil den die ukraine gegenüber
russland hat ausgleichen wir werden der
letzte von heimischen
verteidigungsfähigkeiten dieser die zwei
hat in den vergangenen jahren sowohl von
lehrern nato als auch von der
europäischen union unterstützt voll sind
es gab und gibt
ausbildungsprogramme es gab und gibt
auch
waffenlieferungen
ich glaube die vereinigten staaten haben
seit 20 14 2,5 milliarden
militärische ausbildungshilfe an die
ukraine geliefert oder gegeben aber
unterm strich so wie sie es angedeutet
haben ist es so dass die ua einem
partners stabs wenn auch ein besonderer
patenstadt der allianz ist und
dementsprechend
nun ja also keinen
mitgliedstaates hat also ja jetzt wird
die eine militärisch nicht verteidigen
das sehe ich zumindestens nicht so das
würde wahrscheinlich auch hier in
westeuropa und innerhalb der nato im
niemand behaupten herr stegner es gibt
jetzt auch reaktionen aus kiew zu diesem
verhalten der bundesregierung zu sagen
es gibt keine waffen auch nicht die über
estland der bei uns wohl bekannte vitali
klitschko der bürgermeister von kiew
anzeiger hat die hat das bezeichnet als
unterlassene hilfeleistung und verrat an
freunden was die deutschen machen würden
dort sich da eine neue ein neues
spannungsverhältnis auf wir haben ja
auch gegenüber diesem land durchaus auch
historische verpflichtung ich glaube
dass nicht die rolle deutscher ist nicht
waffenlieferant zu sein sondern sich um
diplomatie zu kümmern wenn es jetzt zwei
dinge tun zum einen eine gemeinsame
antwort geben für den fall dass eine
militärische version stattfindet die
wird es geben rentner gemeinsam dann
würde es geben aber alles dafür zu tun
dass du nicht stattfindet und das machen
nicht durch wettrüsten oder auch in
sachen die fand übrigens finde ich auch
die unterscheidung zwischen offensiv und
defensivwaffen das ist was für gomez das
ist sehr sehr schwierig das einander
zwar nicht ab ist das die falsche rolle
ist und die ukrainische regierung redet
über uns öffentlich auch anders als die
internen gespräche sind und man sehr
wohl weiß warum deutschland die rolle
einnimmt und im koalitionsvertrag der
ampel koalition steht ein sehr kluger
satz nämlich dass die politik gegenüber
russland in europa eine sein muss die
den unterschiedlichen positionen von
bedrohungen rechnung trägt wenn wir
sagen dass ein verteidigungsbündnis wir
tun ja niemand etwas ist dass unsere
sicht der dinge das ist auch eine andere
sicht der dinge gibt muss man mindestens
ineinander zu einem politik einbeziehen
wenn man verhindern möchte dass es zu
konflikten kommen es gibt gute beispiele
aus der vergangenheit und man kann immer
aus der geschichte lernen das ist nicht
abgeschlossen man kann aus immer lernen
die zeigen dass schwierige eskalation
verhindert worden sind dadurch dass man
sich in die andere seite versetzt hat
das prominenteste beispiel ist das schon
schön keine gegner kuba krise wohl gegen
den rat der gesetz des gesamten
establishments der militärischen führung
der wirt wirtschaft der politik sich
dafür entschieden hat sich in die rolle
seines russischen gegenüber zu
versetzung das hat ist am ende friedlich
gern mit glücklicherweise das werfen
wodurch der dritte weltkrieg gewesen und
deswegen will ich die situation nicht
vergleichen aber schon sagen zur
politischen klugheit gehört dazu auch
die perspektive auch wenn man sie nicht
teil des anderen einzunehmen und da hat
sich das natürlich für russland auch
sehr negativ verändert dass die nato
mächtig herangerückt an russland und
natürlich empfinden die russen das
anders als wir das betrachten was nichts
daran ändert dass wir selbstverständlich
eine nato verpflichtung gegenüber
unseren polnischen nachbarn gegenüber
den baltischen nachbarn die in der nato
sind aber die ukraine ist nicht von
ungefähr nicht in der nato und es steht
uns auch nicht anders in die nato kommt
sie ist weit davon entfernt
nato-mitglied war putin auch das weiß
putin auch aber es ist gut dass
festzustellen und ich bin manchmal ein
bisschen besorgt darüber wie
leichtsinnig und wie leichtfertig
interviews gegeben werden denn
diplomatie findet eben nicht vor kameras
und vom mikrofon station hinter
verschlossenen türen und da muss klar
gemacht wenn es gibt eine gemeinsame
reaktion wenn hier in der invasion
stattfindet und alles ändern wenn das
das nicht stattfindet und vielleicht ein
letztes mal muss ja auch bedenken es
gibt so viele gemeinsame interessen die
wir russland hätten darüber reden
momentan niemanden wir diese situation
vergiftet ist und an ihre balkone sind
das liegt nicht an uns also wie gut dass
analysen und strategiediskussion vor
laufenden kameras stattfinden kann
selbst wenn diplomatische aktivitäten
hinter verschlossenen türen stattfinden
erwartet ich stelle noch eine frage die
schon letzte woche zu diesem thema
gestellt habe machen wir vielleicht im
westen auch ein fehler dass wir
dieses gefühl eingekreist zu werden der
russen nicht ernst genug nehmen jetzt
mal unabhängig davon ob das überhaupt
gerechtfertigt ist so wahrscheinlich ist
es ja nicht gerechtfertigt aber dass wir
uns einfach zu wenig da rein versetzen
nein ich bin durchaus dafür dass man so
etwas in betracht zieht da der kollege
stegner an der stelle recht dass man
auch sich in die position moskaus hinein
versetzt da das ist vollkommen in
ordnung aber man muss schon die maßstäbe
waren
die nahtlos ein defensiv bündnis und hat
keinerlei offensive absicht das hat sie
nie gehabt zu sie setzt sich zusammen
aus staaten die sich freiwillig
entschieden haben ihr beizutreten
also diejenigen die mitglied sind auch
ehemals der sowjetunion angehören wie
die baltischen staaten
haben sich freiwillig dazu entschieden
und ich glaube das prinzip wollen wir
doch alle nicht aufgeben das sollte man
auch nicht in frage stellen und das was
jetzt stattfindet am um die ukraine
herum ist ja kein wettrüsten herr
kollege stegner sondern ist ein massiver
truppenaufmarsch von russischer seite
mit etwa der hälfte der kräfte der
russischen streitkräfte und da ist nun
überhaupt nichts aggressives weder von
ukrainischer seite noch von westlicher
seite sondern das ist wirklich eine
einseitige aggression und nun haben wir
zusätzlich die erfahrung mit russland
seit 2014 dass russland bereit und in
der lage ist auch unter verletzung von
verträgen die die russland selber oder
die vorgänger der vorgänger stadt wird
nun geschlossen hat bereit ist eigene
interessen auch mit militärischer gewalt
auch mit hybriden mitteln rechtswidrig
durchzusetzen und deswegen muss man
natürlich an dieser stelle befürchten
dass das erneut geschieht ist nicht
irgend jemand der dort truppen an
sammelt sondern ein stark der schon mal
und ford wäre seit 2014 die souveränität
der ukraine verletzung wo es ständig zu
kriegshandlungen kommen ständig zu toten
kommt derzeit eher pp und deswegen muss
man an der stelle schon sagen ist
natürlich diplomatie richtig ist die
ausgestreckte hand richtig ist die
perzeption der russischen sicht richtig
aber muss man an der stelle ein signal
der klarheit und auch der härte gegen
russland setzen sonst wird man russland
an der stelle nicht stoppen und da muss
man sehr darauf achten wir sind in einer
entscheidungsphase und da muss man klare
signale geben und das fängt beim so zu
meiner wortwahl an deswegen finde ich
den wortwahl wettrüsten an der stelle
verkehrt bin keine ausführen wettrüsten
aber da muss man sehr klar machen dass
das inakzeptabel ist und dass der westen
darauf sehr geschlossen antworten wird
wenn auch die ukraine natürlich nicht
nato mitglied ist und natürlich nicht im
verteidigungs- und fall den bündnisfall
von artikel 5 auslösen klar geschlossen
hat zeigt der westen moment aber auch
nicht unbedingt heute rowland gelegt das
problem auch darin dass sich dass
russland die agenda verändert hat die
sicherheitspolitische agenda aus ihrer
sicht und viele entwicklungen
entscheidungen aus den letzten 30 jahren
also vor allem im jahr 1990 bis 197
rückgängig machen möchte oder jedenfalls
so geändert haben möchte dass es mehr
einfluss auf die sicherheitspolitik in
europa hat
ja wenn man das ganze historisch
betrachtet also zumindest die letzten 30
jahre sich anschaut dann wissen wir dass
präsident putin es für einen
kardinalfehler hält das mal an
deutschland gestattet hat über seine
bündniszugehörigkeit
selbst zu entscheiden dass man die
souveränität der der ehemaligen
sowjetrepubliken also auch konkrete
baltischen staaten so einfach aufgegeben
hat dass man es zugelassen hat dass
diese länder in aus mitteleuropa in die
nato aufgenommen werden wollten als er
möchte gerne die entwicklungen die sich
in den 90 er mitte der neunziger jahre
ergeben haben revidieren das hat er sehr
klar gesagt und er möchte zweitens gerne
die einfluss wäre russlands staates
halten
man sieht das an seiner intervention in
belarus
als er den diktator lukaschenko gestützt
hat das ist strategisch ja auch nicht
uninteressant dass als folge jetzt auch
russische truppen in belarus stationiert
sind um die ukraine sozusagen von drei
seiten in die zange zu nehmen und man
sieht das an kasachstan man sieht es in
syrien also wir haben es mit einem sehr
selbstbewussten russischen präsidenten
zu tun der die einflusssphäre russlands
vergrößern möchte und der dritte punkt
ist es ist ein russischer präsident der
unbedingt auf augenhöhe mit den usa
sprechen möchte und da hat die trump
administration natürlich viel schaden
angerichtet weil sie einfach russland
ich sag mal so beschönigt aber auch an
der seite hat liegen lassen jetzt haben
wir also beiden im weißen haus und hier
hofft punkten jetzt größeren größere
akzeptanz zu finden und wieder mit ihm
auf augenhöhe sprechen zu können als
macht anerkannt zu werden
gut da hat ja auch schon in der
auseinandersetzung mit barack obama das
war ja damals der präsident zweiten
version ist da ja auch schon auch im
westen in relation gegeben ich würde
gerne mal einen kurzen blick von der
außen sicherheits politik in die
deutsche politik wenden denn es ist ja
auch ein innenpolitisches thema zb in
ihrer partei der bundeskanzler olaf
scholz hat sich ja zunächst mal in
dieser frage ziemlich lange bedeckt
gehalten wollte ja auch die neue
gaspipeline nord stream zwei aus dem
ganzen also im ganzen konflikt
raushalten sei ja nur ein
privatwirtschaftliches projekt da hat er
jetzt einen schwenk gemacht also er hat
auch russland gedroht im falle
militärische eskalation
wird auch deutschland sich an sanktionen
beteiligen hat ausdrücklich trotzdem
zwei nicht mehr ausgeschlossen ihr denn
da noch auf der linie seiner partei die
ja da in sachen russland eigentlich in
der relativ deutliche auch
deeskalierende auch moderierende
position hat auf keinen fall mit
sanktionen zu tun oder jedenfalls nicht
den konfrontationskurs mit russland zu
suchen heute war immer noch einmal zu
gast in berlin der da auch eine ziemlich
deutliche meinung hat vertritt der
bundeskanzler noch die position seiner
partei in dieser frage das tut und ich
glaube das wird dann sehr deutlich dass
wir nicht über werte geleitete politik
oder realitätsbezogen fertig reden
sondern wir reden über beides man kann
nicht einfach sphären zugestehen man
kann nicht sagen völker haben kein
selbstbestimmungsrecht und
man sollte nicht sanktionen jetzt aus
buchstabieren in öffentlichen drohungen
aber man muss zur kenntnis nehmen dass
es diese einflusssphären gibt dass die
kleinen nicht dem nächsten die nato
eintreten wird und das natürlich wenn es
zudem mit höheren inversion kämen wenn
ich einfach das gas laufen wird das wird
nicht so sein aber es macht wenig sinn
vorher sanktionsdrohungen zu haben wie
das jetzt ganz viele tun immer noch da
ist dass das und das das wird ja nicht
passieren sondern man muss als ziel
diplomatische bemühungen haben dass es
das nicht gibt und ich glaube wenn ich
vorhin gesagt nicht am ende an meine ich
damit auch dass er konkrete vorschläge
gemacht werden in solchen gesprächen
kann zum beispiel zu der vereinbarung
kommen dass es transparenz gibt über
militärische manöver auf beiden seiten
man könnte zu einer vereinbarung kommen
das militärische personal und
infrastruktur auch von beiden seiten der
grenze entfernt wird man könnte zu der
vereinbarung kommen dass man es von
beiden seiten stärker umbesetzungen ist
auch in die richtung geht das wären
alles dinge die man tun könnte wo soll
eine militärische operation denn
hinführen es ist ja vorhin zu recht
gesagt worden keiner kann sich und mag
sich vorstellen dass wir hier ein krieg
mitten in europa haben in denen wir
verwickelt sind als kriegsteilnehmer
dass das kann ja wohl nicht das ziel
sein sondern die frage ist ja
was jetzt auch immer passiert wenn die
situation weiter eskaliere das wissen
wir alle nicht das will auch niemand
aber könnte der bundeskanzler in die
situation kommen dass er entweder seine
bündnispartner verprellt oder den von
ihnen zb repräsentiert und linken flügel
der spd der auf keinen fall diese
sanktionsmechanismen
auch die androhung wien gegen russland
finde es sehr schön welchen einfluss der
linke flügel der spd haben er wird in
seiner position karikiert die spd ist
friedenspartei die spd ist die partei
schon willy brandt und helmut schmidt
und helmut schmidt hat gesagt lass uns
lieber 100 stunden ergebnislos
verhandeln als eine minute schießen und
das ist eben auch ein punkt die rolle
die deutschland hat übrigens ein land
das im letzten jahrhundert furchtbare
greul angerichtet hat überall in europa
dass dieses land hat die hauptsächlich
verpflichtung mit dazu beizutragen durch
diplomatisches geschick und
beharrlichkeit dass es dazu nicht kommt
und nicht ständig zu spekulieren und
womöglich mit die eskalationsspirale
anzuhalten wenn ich also jetzt drohen
mit sanktionen mit wirtschaftlichen
sanktionen öffentlich permanent wo soll
der sinn liegen was ob das heim putin
beeindruckt wenn es markigen reden vom
bundestagsabgeordneten hätte ich große
zweifel sondern es muss hinter
verschlossenen türen deutlich sein dass
das bündnis zusammenhält und im zweiten
fall gemeinsam handelt das ist schlau
und nicht das andere und deswegen glaube
ich ist moslem zwei etwas worüber man
natürlich auch ökonomische
meinungsverschiedenheiten haben mit den
usa zum beispiel mit anderen das ist uns
unter freunden durchaus normal dass man
nicht in jedem punkt einer meinung ist
und die großen haben selbst in zeiten
des kalten krieges energie geliefert das
ja auch ein teil der wahrheit hat da
keine rolle gespielt aber natürlich
würde es nicht business as usual geben
wenn ich eine militärinvasion
stattfindet weiß jeder dass weiß auch
putin und das ist der gegenstand der
verhandlung über die wir reden und
nochmal man muss hier nicht den
bundeskanzler gegen die partei schieben
oder zu schieben versuchen die spd ist
friedenspartei insgesamt und sie trägt
in der regierung mit dazu bei dass
diplomatische bemühungen für die
bundesregierung forderungen scheinen
frau berbalk hat klipp und klar erklärt
es gibt keine waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine dänischen der deutlichkeit sie
zwar auch nicht aber sie hat auch im
koalitionsvertrag mit unterschrieben wo
klar ist das ist eine unabhängige
energie behörde gibt die das genehmigt
und die politik sich da raushält
und dass es dazu kommen wird und der
streit über neue streiks beendet werden
mit dem koalitionsvertrag oder er kommt
wieder auf wenn es in osteuropa doch
noch zu einer verschärften situation
kommt sie haben rote linien gezogen
erwarte von was den ukraine konflikt
angeht jetzt glänzt die union ja auch
mit widersprüchlichkeiten sie sagen also
da muss man
die gangart einschlagen der csu
vorsitzende markus söder hat gesagt dass
er sei gegen wirtschaftssanktionen auch
dagegen dass trotzdem zwei nicht in
betrieb ging da ist er ja dann bei ihnen
normalerweise gehört er ja nicht ihren
allerbesten freund anarbeiten den
wahlkampf also er ist gegen
wirtschaftssanktionen weil uns das
selbst schaden würde ihr neuer
parteivorsitzender friedrich merz hat
gesagt also ein anderes mögliches
sanktionsinstrument dass er wirksam ist
nämlich russland aus dem zahlungssystem
swift rauszuwerfen
das wäre auch ganz schlecht weil das sei
eine atombombe der für die finanzmärkte
dass für das weltfinanzsystem das muss
er ja wissen aufgrund seiner früheren
beruflichen erfahrung
solche äußerungen von der union in
dieser frage wird ja möglicherweise im
kreml auch freudentaumel auslösen na
also vielen dank für die dass sie uns so
viel politischen einfluss zu sprechen
aber da würden sie uns wahrscheinlich
doch ein bisschen überschätzen aber es
ganz klar wir haben das als union auch
öffentlich gesagt und ich verantworte
die außen- und verteidigungspolitik
meiner fraktion wir dürfen jetzt nicht
ausschließen alles ist auf dem tisch
dazu gehören alle instrumentarien und
dazu gehörten und das ist nicht die
hauptsache aber im zweifel auch
jedenfalls die ermöglichung von
waffenlieferungen wenn andere das täten
da darf man sich als deutscher nicht
dazwischen werfen die position die der
kollege stegner hier vertreten hat ist
eine andere position als wie die
bundesregierung vertritt die
bundesregierung sagt wir müssen mit
wirtschaftssanktionen drohen für den
fall dass und das finde ich auch richtig
man muss einen preis benennen wenn es
eine weitere und erneute verletzung
geben würde glaube das muss das muss
ganz deutlich wenn das ist ja nicht das
ist ja nicht alles aber ohne
jetzt eine härtung eine klarheit in
dieser position werden wir insgesamt
nichts werden und dazu gehören
umfangreiche maßnahmen die abgestimmt
sind innerhalb europas wenn der tat
dankbar dass immer mehr da ist und
gemeinsam mit dem bundeskanzler
dort jetzt auch eine linie gezogen hat
das noch mal bekräftigt habe das auch
hier wir zusammenstehen machen meine
informationen gibt es auch jetzt was ja
auch erforderlich war eine sehr enge
abstimmung mit den vereinigten staaten
von amerika denn wir brauchen hier keine
unterschiede im westlichen bündnis das
ist genau das worauf russland an der
stelle abzielt und dazu muss man dann
sagen der gesamte finanzbereich der
gesamte bankenbereich das gesamte
finanzierungssystem wie auch natürlich
unsere wirtschaftlichen kontakte stehen
dann zur dispositionen da kann man jetzt
noch in zwei nicht
ausnehmen aber das kann auch nicht das
einzige sein was dann betroffen wäre das
möchte ich auch schon klar dazu sagen
das müssten dann also alle anderen im
westen im westen auch bereit sein ihre
wirtschaftsbeziehungen auch ihre energie
wirtschaftlichen beziehungen genauso zur
disposition stellen wie wir dazu bereit
sind nur ich glaube was klar sein muss
ist dass deutschland in der tat eine
historische verantwortung wenn ich beim
kollegen stecken aber die haben wir
übrigens nicht nur gegenüber russland
die haben ja auch gegenüber der um keine
die schlimmsten zeile wenn ich das noch
sagen darf die studierte oder die
schlimmsten
dinge die im zweiten weltkrieg durch die
deutsche wehrmacht wird der deutschland
verantwortung durch gemacht worden sind
schlimmsten menschenrechtsverletzungen
auch
dass das was im kriege gemacht wurde ist
auf ukrainischem boden geschehen und
deswegen haben wir eben auch über
gegenüber der ukraine und der
ukrainischen bevölkerung eine
verantwortung nicht nur gegenüber allen
anderen sondern speziell auch gegen der
über der ukraine und das ist sozusagen
nicht mehr einzelne frage wo man sagt
russland gegenüber eine hohe
verantwortung müssen uns zurückhalten
nein auch gegenüber der ukraine da warne
ich sehr davor da irgendwie zu
unterscheiden das mahnt uns zu einer
gewissen zurückhaltung aber das mahnt
uns auch zur wachsamkeit denn wir im
letzten jahrhundert zwei weltkriege
erlebt
einer indem man sozusagen als
schlafwandler hinein marschiert ist und
sowas müsste man ist man jetzt sehr
aufmerksam aber ein anderer der
verursacht wurde weil die freie welt
nicht zur härte gegenüber einem diktator
bereit war und diesen fehler darf man
eben auch nicht wiederholen in
ausdrücklich recht geben was die ukraine
angeht und polen und russland die
schrecklich gelitten haben unter der
nazi war bereit aber an einem punkt will
ich ihnen widersprechen der
bundeskanzler hat ausdrücklich nicht mit
sanktionen gedroht das hat er eben genau
nicht getan sondern er hat in interview
der süddeutschen zeitung heute auch in
der pressekonferenz mit immer noch
einmal klar gesagt wir müssen bereit
sein wenn es zu dieser militärinvasion
kommt zu einer entschlossenen reaktion
das muss auch gesagt werden aber unser
ziel muss sein das zu verhindern eben
genau das nicht zu tun was sie tun und
andere tun mit waffenlieferung drohen
mit sanktionen wenn denn das hat der
bundeskanzler ausdrücklich nicht getan
sondern er hat gesagt wir haben uns
verständigt darauf das ist für den fall
eine gemeinsame reaktion geben wird aber
das ist nicht gegenstand unserer
kommunikation ihrer sondern ging schon
unser kommunikation ist zu verhindern
dass es dazu kommt dass die holländer
die mathematik da unterscheiden wir uns
deswegen das ist ihre position wir haben
eine andere aber die bundesregierung hat
das auch nicht so vertreten die großen
herkömmlichen der unterschied zwischen
einer warnung und einer drohung ist
derjenige dass man warnen kann vor einem
unwetter auf dass man keinen einfluss
hat und eine drohung da war man von
etwas auf das man einfluss hat und hier
ist sozusagen eine warnung davor dass
der westen auch deutschland maßnahmen
ergreifen würde insofern ist es eine
drohung sie wissen auch als vater
wahrscheinlich dass es mit drohungen
soll der sache ist also drohung sind
kein gutes mittel um seine ziele zu
erreichen sondern das wissen auf der
anderen seite ist die entschlossenheit
vorhanden ist das ist völlig ausreichend
und es hilft der diplomatie sehr viel
mehr als magische ende das ist aber an
der stelle ganz klar gehört zum
instrumentarium des westens wasser
anwendet und das ist konsens von
washington bis nach warschau dass wir an
der stelle klar ankündigen dass wir
maßnahmen ergreifen ob sie das drohung
nennen oder wie immer sie das nennen
natürlich soll das alles vermieden
werden dass es eintritt aber nur dadurch
dass sie das klar ankündigen können sie
sozusagen die folge vermeiden und da ist
die bundesregierung zum glück sehr klar
und übrigen zum thema waffenlieferung
möchte ich nur noch mal sagen dass ihr
koalitionspartner fdp durch die
vorsitzende des verteidigungsausschusses
vorstadt zimmermann gesagt hat dass sie
sich das vorstellen kann und dass sie
auch der an der seite
ihr meine position unterstützt und dass
auch vizekanzler robert habeck vor
eintritt in die regierung das schon
gesehen hat da muss ich ihnen respekt
zollen da hat er früher gesehen was
wahrscheinlich notwendig sein würde
insofern position wenn wir wieder von
den großen fdp in der bundesregierung
vertreten
pakistan kommt regen auf diese frage am
ende der sondern noch mal zurück herbst
ich habe es vorhin schon gesagt sie
waren eher haben ja auf bitten des
damaligen
nato-generalsekretärs rasmussen ja einen
planungsstab bei der nato aufgebaut ist
aber der vorausschauende strategie
zuständig waren können sie mal ein
bisschen aus dem nähkästchen plaudern
was hat dieser staat eigentlich gemacht
was war das vorausschauende was war die
strategischen aufgaben und wie würde man
jetzt in einer solchen situation auf
nato ebene
reagieren die nato ist sich ja wir haben
ja darüber jetzt in der sendung
gesprochen in einigen einige
nato-staaten sind sich da nicht einige
es gibt unterschiedliche akzente
unterschiedliche wünsche
unterschiedliche strategien was muss man
sich vorstellen wie haben sie da
gearbeitet
also das team das ich geleitet habe ein
zivil militärisches team was sowohl den
generalsekretär als auch den
vorsitzenden des militärausschusses
unterstützt hat und wir haben uns ganz
simpel auszudrücken versucht
aus der sagen wir mal medialen
international politische geräuschkulisse
signal herauszufinden oder finger
herauszufiltern die uns in die lage
versetzt haben daraus plausible
schlüssel zu team für das mögliche
weitere verhalten von bestimmten
staatlichen oder nichtstaatlichen
akteuren
bestimmten trends die wir auf regionaler
und globaler ebene gesehen haben aber
wir haben natürlich auch immer
handlungsempfehlungen abgegeben wie
würde und sollte sich in einer
bestimmten szenario beispielsweise das
bündnis verhalten und wir haben eine
schwerpunktmäßig was sie nicht
überraschen mag zu russland gearbeitet
wir haben sehr viel zu china gearbeitet
zu anderen grossen regionalen und
wichtigen akteuren wir haben auch zur
funktionalen themen gearbeitet wie
beispielsweise zur entwicklung von
technologien und ihrer wirkung auf
militärische
auseinandersetzungen auf warfarin meinem
englischen sagt aber um auch russland
zurück zu kommen ich habe in der tat
wird meinen kollegen sehr sehr viel zeit
damit verbracht szenarien zu schreiben
über
die art und weise wie russland eben auf
uns aber auch auf andere internationale
impulse reagieren könnte und ich denke
mal dass das etwas sehr wichtiges ist
was in den hauptstädten aber auch in
brüssel unternommen werden soll ich
glaube herr stegner sagte oder erwartet
ich bin sehr recht es ist immer wichtig
sich in die motivation des jeweils
anderen hineinversetzen und den punkt
den ich noch mal hier unterstreichen
möchte ist unsere debatte auch die die
wir jetzt führen wird natürlich in
moskau verfolgt aber nicht nur sie wird
auch in china die chinesen das ist
vielleicht noch ein weiterer aspekt den
man mit einführung kann betrachten das
was wir hier gegenwärtig als krisenhafte
entwicklungen europa erleben sehr genau
sie schauen sehr darauf wie unsere
politische geschlossenheit
funktioniert oder auch nicht sie schauen
auf das was wir debattieren
zum thema wirtschaftssanktionen sie
schauen auf die militärischen
fähigkeiten die wir bereit sind wird
falls ihr die waagschale zu werfen zur
verteidigung unserer mitglieder und das
alles tun sie natürlich mit blick auf
ihre eigenen sicherheits politischen
ambitionen
das betrifft primär die frage der
wiedervereinigung taiwans aber auch
andere ambitionen die ist im
südchinesischen meer hat wir haben es
ein bisschen zu tun finde ich mit dem
was ich mal als strategische
gleichzeitigkeit
bezeichnen möchte nämlich mit wirklich
zwei bis an die zähne bewaffneten
nuklearen kontinentalen mächte russland
und china die einen sehr engen
schulterschluss akzeptieren das werden
wir im übrigen am vierten februar bei
der eröffnung der olympischen
winterspiele in bing noch mal sehen wenn
präsident die sich mit putin treffen
wird die beide vehement gegen die
liberale werfe werteordnung und
weltordnung agieren und einer von beiden
nämlich china hat in der tat alle
möglichkeiten
technologisch wirtschaftlich militärisch
und auch sonstige um eben diese
internationale ordnung zu verändern ich
will ihnen hier kein vortrag darüber
halten aber ich möchte einfach den punkt
machen dass die debatte die wir hier
führen zum thema waffenlieferungen in
der ukraine
aus meiner sicht eine viel weitere
dimension hat immer die hier nicht nur
in deutschland sondern natürlich auch
ein bündnis reden müssen wir haben nicht
viel zeit zum reden denn diese beiden
continental möchte werden weiter akten
schaffen da würde ich mir sehr viel
deutschen politik wünschen aber auch
natürlich von dem der andere
bündnispartner dass wir ganz konkret
gegen vorschläge machen wie wir jetzt
auch der russischen seite präsentieren
können möglichst natürlich gemeinsame
und unter einbeziehung der ukraine und
georgiens und diese gegen vorschläge
sollten dann in der tat auf einem ja auf
einen deal um diesen begriff zu nutzen
hinauslaufen der sowohl russische
forderungen erfüllt vor allen dingen mit
blick auf die künftige
erweiterungsrunden der nato aber auch
seitens der russen dinge einfordern wie
beispielsweise dem rückzug ihrer
unterstützung aus der parodistischen die
bieten wir brauchen eine zone in europa
geben wenn sie so wollen
sicherheitspolitisch gestalten müssen
und ich finde um aus der defensive
heraus zu frauen in der wir uns von hand
putin haben drängen lassen ist es
wirklich höchste zeit dass wir
konzeptionelle vorschläge gemeinsam und
nicht nur auf
frau frauke wenn diese entwicklung wenn
diese
verhandlungen aber scheitern die frau
gab es da gerade angedeutet hat und es
wird sich weiter die lage verschärfen
wird deutschland doch noch in eine
situation kommen zum beispiel waffen
liefern zu müssen
also wir wissen nicht ganz genau auf was
präsident tut ihnen da verfolgt einige
punkte sind sehr klar geworden er möchte
eigentlich vom westen ein zugeständnis
dass die ukraine nicht in die nato
aufgenommen wird und auch regieren wie
ich vorhin schon erwähnte dass die
baltischen länder in der nato sind dass
polen in der nato ist er hat also sein
ziel war erreicht dass er von den
amerikanern sehr ernst genommen wird
aber er hat auch andere länder
aufgeschreckt als das in schweden und
finnland die sich jetzt laut gedanken
machen ob sie ihre bündnis neutralität
aufgegeben zugunsten der nato mitglied
und er hat außerdem in der ukraine dafür
gesorgt dass die bevölkerung im
westlichen teil der ukraine die
mehrheitsbevölkerung immer stärker und
immer lauter dahin drängt in die
westlichen bündnisse aufgenommen zu
werden weil diese entwicklung in der
indie in die westlichen bündnisses zu
bringen gibt es ja schon länger
waffenlieferungen sie halte sich
wahrscheinlich für möglich halten sie
für ausgeschlossen auch wenn sich die
situation weiter zu spät weise eskaliert
in einen krieg deutschlands rolle ist
nicht kriegsteilnehmer und
waffenlieferant zu sein sondern für
diplomatie zu sorgen und dass wir damit
mächten reden die unsere werte nicht
teilen das ist schon lange so wir nur
mit den reden würden die unsere werte
teilen sind wenn norwegen island allein
also da muss man mit dahin reden das ist
so waffenlieferungen sind nicht alles
aber jetzt wie die bundesregierung zu
sagen wir liefern lazarette ist schon
fast zynisch wir müssen jetzt klar der
seite der ukraine stehen gut wir werden
das beobachten die nächsten tage und
wochen werden da möglicherweise sehr
viel mehr aufschluss geben ich bedanke
mich bei christiane lemke bei stefanie
babst bei johann wadephul und bei ralf
stegner liebe zuschauer morgen in der
phoenix runde das thema die
gewissensfrage der bundestag streitet
über die impfpflicht morgen nachmittag
ab 13 uhr live bei phoenix bundestag
zunächst die befragung der
bundesregierung dass robert habeck und
dann ab ca 15 uhr diese sogenannte
orientierungs orientierungs debatte zum
zur frage soll deutschland die
allgemeine impfpflicht einführen oder
nicht jetzt folgt felix der tag mit
mayer weber darin unter anderem die
haben das in dieser sendung auch schon
angesprochen die pressekonferenz von
olaf scholz mit dem französischen
präsidenten emanuel makro heute abend in
berlin bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]